petit matin il fait 0 degré sur les
falaises du grand bénare les chercheurs
de l'université de la réunion ont
installé leur camp avancé sur une
corniche à 2500 mètres d'altitude au
coeur des réserves du parc national
ils ont entrepris depuis quelques années
une étude sur le pétrel de barau
cet animal endémiques de la réunion
probablement présents sur notre île
vianne avant l'homme est aujourd'hui en
danger
ouais c'est bien lui il est mag est
peut-être leur peser tant qu on y est 70
70 en cette période de nidification
matthieu le corre et patrick pinet
prospects toute la journée les colonies
découverte lors des précédentes missions
et en cherchent de nouvelles de nombreux
oiseaux sont ainsi identifiés de mathieu
il ya un autre cadavre ici il est bagué
de bagues fx fx
ouais abc des premières séries qu'on a
posé quand on a commencé notre fauteuil
non c'est 96 97
fx 67-66 vieille bikes d'amazon a été
récupéré par la saur
au moment des opérations de sauvetage
vacances avec le problème des éclairages
artificiels
ouais et puis voilà on la bagheera
relâché et voilà on le retrouve dix ans
après sur colonies
à partir de la deuxième semaine d'avril
les juvéniles sont prêts à l'envol la
nuit attirés par les reflets de lune sur
la mer
ils se lancent des auteurs du deuxième
sommet de l'île pour leur premier vol
hélas trompés par les lumières de la
ville beaucoup s'écrase pour ne plus
repartir depuis quelques années une
chaîne de solidarité s'est créée autour
du pétrel de barau
les écoliers de cilaos des bénévoles de
la seor des agents du parc national et
bien d'autres encore tentent de
récupérer de soigner et de relâcher les
survivants
m
il a dû taper dans le chai pas dans le
poteau on va rechercher un autre
on va voir si on a d'autres qui sont
attirés par la lumière ils décidé cette
année tombe là je suis un salut battus
eux y avoir fait quelque chose pour toi
je passe voilà un mais les pétrels et un
deuxième mais soudain par contre il est
en bon état
ah bon alors sud a été trouvé hier soir
au butor dans un magasin dans un
rez-de-chaussée de la gazière auquel on
a envie de partir pour mieux comprendre
leur comportement qu les chercheurs ont
mis au point une expérience consistant à
équiper quelques oiseaux de balises
argos afin de suivre leurs déplacements
en période d'alimentation
ils ventilent il ventile mais vous voyez
là mais la balise elle est bien
positionnée en plein soleil
il n'y a pas de plumes au dessus tout va
bien à la lumière là ils ventilent à
fond attention il va se lâcher
ouais mais de retour au laboratoire le
décodage des trajets donne des résultats
saisissants là quand 48 heures le
prolongement du plateau continental de
madagascar est atteint au fond et ils
ont l'air d'être tous de part et d'autre
de ceux de ceux au fond c'est clair et
puis temps d'un café café un trajet
court ils nourrissent le poussin et puis
perdre du poids et puis au bout d'un
certain seuil de poids edit bon là c'est
pour moi donc ils partent en trajets
longs croyable alors que on est en
période d'élevage et qu' il faut quand
même qu'ils aillent nourrir le poussant
le plus souvent possible et il ya les
premiers sur la sur la crête en face
patrick aujourd'hui le parc national de
la réunion veut porter un message fort
pour mettre en place le principe de nuit
sans lumière pendant les pics d'envol du
mois d'avril
ainsi pour longtemps encore les pétrels
de barau pour ont paradé au dessus de la
mer de nuages et venir nicher sur les
hautes falaises du grand bénare